hi everyone
er hopefully you can hear me okay if not
tell me so my name is
alone and i'll be talking to you about
native speed on the web
javascript and smjs so
we're talking about the web
it's the biggest open standards-based
platform that we have
so it's a great way to reach people you
just give them a url and they can just
get to your site get to your code so it
would be great if it were fast too
because then hey we could just send
people directly to our code
in the simplest way possible so how fast
is the web right now there are many
complaints
there are many things that are not as
fast as they could be and often the
complaints are very justified
but just to clarify so speed is
determined by many different separate
things
the dom graphics javascript
this talk is only about javascript so
this is just one aspect of speed
obviously it depends on
other things so how fast is javascript
these these days so again there are many
different factors to consider
the jit garbage collector etc but
one way i think that's interesting to
measure is to take a large real world
application a native app basically and
see how that works so the epic citadel
demo
which launched about six months ago is
one way to see so i'm actually running
in a browser now it's firefox and i'll
just launch the demo
so as i said this is epic citadel it's
uh the unreal engine 3 from
epic games it's basically about a
million lines
of sql plus compiled here into
javascript
and you can see it running in the
browser so this is not using any plugins
not using flash this is just
javascript and webgl and if you go to
full screen you can pretty much forget
that it's a not just a native app and of
course it's fully
interactive can walk around
look around there's even a benchmark
mode where
you can see it's about 58 to 60 frames
per second so it's running pretty
pretty well over here
okay so as i said it's a large
real world c plus code base compiled
with
ms script and into javascript
and the output uses just standard web
technologies just javascript and
web gl as i said and i think this kind
of shows that you can run native apps
on the web this is a native app it
normally runs natively but you can run
it on the web too without anything
non-standard
so as i said this demo launched about
six months ago and you might have seen
it
back then so what i want to talk about
is what changed since then so
the demo itself of course is the same as
it always was but browsers have
gotten better so back then when it
launched the demo only ran
in firefox not because there was
anything special about firefox but
because again it just use standards
based things but
it's a very large complex app and it
sort of stressed some issues that other
browsers
had a few small bugs in but many of
those bugs were fixed for example in
chrome today the demo runs in both
firefox and chrome very well back then
the demo took about 20 seconds
to start up so startup includes parsing
the javascript
running it optimizing it it also
actually runs the game engine
so it's actually loading all the data
from the file system
it's sending stuff to the gpu it's doing
a lot of work this takes several seconds
in a native build
so at the time i was actually pretty
happy to get to 20 seconds on the web
but today if you run it in firefox it
takes about 10 seconds
so it's gotten a lot better and back
then this ran at about 40 frames per
second
in firefox today it runs in 60 frames
per second in both firefox and chrome as
i showed you in firefox but again it
runs in chrome just as well
same frame rate and this is actually an
understatement because
browsers cap the frame rate at 60
because there's no point in rendering
more than the user can see it just
wastes
processing power so they can actually do
much better so there have been big
speed ups in just six months
so we've seen you can run a native app
why isn't everything on the web
super fast so javascript engines do not
always run at their maximal speed
all modern browsers have very powerful
complex
js engines that can do amazing things
but the javascript language has some
aspects which make it tricky to optimize
so this is what motivated the smgs
project
which is basically an easy to optimize
subset
of javascript so here's a small sample
if you know javascript this the should
be readable even though it's probably
not the style of code you'd write by
hand
so basically there's a sort of can you
see the cursor i guess so
there's sort of a fibonacci like
function over here
in the sense that when you call it it
returns the sum of the last two elements
in the series so x minus two and x minus
one but it's not quite the fibonacci
because for the first and second
elements if x is less than 2 it returns
a value from the heap which you can see
over here is just
a uint 8 array that is a javascript
typed array
so it's the fibonacci sequence but the
initial values are
user defined so this is javascript
but the smgs subset of javascript which
this is
in is easier to optimize so why three
things i want to point out here first of
all
there's this heap thing which as i
mentioned sort of represents
our our data or the memory that we're
going to use
so the heap variable cannot be changed
or replaced
it's actually captured by the function
fib like
as a closure so it cannot change later
the javascript engine has a static
guarantee that
whenever it sees heap over here it's the
same heap it doesn't need to check if it
changed
so that's helpful this or zero stuff you
may have seen on the line
over here might look a bit puzzling you
probably wouldn't write that
but it's helpful because the or operator
in javascript is a 32-bit operation
so it coerces its inputs to 32 bits
or if zero does nothing so or with zero
just
ensures you have a 32 bit int so
whenever things could underflow like
when we do x minus two
we add in or zero and we have a
guarantee in fact that in this function
all the integer math can be done as
32-bit
so again the javascript engine has a
much much easier task here
and finally we use typed arrays when we
need data so heap here is a typed array
so given the fact that we know heap will
never change and we know that heap is a
typed array
when we read heap of x here the js
engine can literally just emit a load
from memory so this is as efficient as
it gets and this is why things like the
epic citadel demo can run at very close
to native speed
so here's a set of other benchmarks of s
and j s
and i can zoom in a little that's easier
to read
so these are all written in c plus plus
or c they're compiled into javascript
within scriptin so we can compare
directly
native and javascript on the same code
which is nice
and everything is normalized to native
so the numbers are
how much time it ran how many times
slower than native and you can see
firefox and chrome
so lower numbers are better you can see
that on many of these smaller benchmarks
here both firefox and chrome are
somewhere between one to two times
slower than native which is
quite good i think on these larger
benchmarks
the picture is pretty much the same so
there's box 2d and bullet
real world physics engines used in
actual games
java end body is a large amount of java
code compiled ahead of time into c
and then compiled into javascript
there's a benchmark of the lua
vm actually this is a garbage collection
benchmark so it's actually
benchmarking a garbage collector
implemented in javascript
and zlata is a compression library
so again you can see both firefox do
quite well about half the speed of
native
on most of these
so let's focus a little bit on the bucs
2d results so as i mentioned box 2d is a
physics engine if you've played angry
birds then you've played a game that
uses box 2d
it's using a lot of other things because
it's open source and it's great
and so basically the data here was
collected by
jgw and he basically took all the ports
of box2d
from the original c code to everything
he could find any benchmarked at all
so again lower numbers are better one is
the original c code and you can see
multiple
things here there's a java version
there's a few javascript versions
there's actionscript or flash
and there are two versions of javascript
there's the box2d web one which is an
older port that basically uses normal
style javascript there are objects and
properties etc
and in smg support which is just
compiling the c
code directly to smjs
and i think what's interesting to see is
that smgs is faster than
typical quote unquote javascript on the
three browsers where both versions were
tested so just looking at the colors you
can see an
orange firefox on box2d web
and here much closer to native speed is
smgs on firefox
on chrome again there's a speed up going
to smgs on chrome 27
on chrome 30 it's actually much closer
to native
as well and even on internet explorer 10
there's a speed up for mass and js
so this shouldn't be a surprising thing
because as i showed you smgs is very low
level
simple and easy to optimize so it
doesn't
use a lot of things like the garbage
collector it doesn't need
picks doesn't need all these tricks that
are sometimes
hard to guarantee that they run always
fast things like hidden classes are
wonderful but
they're hard to predict smgs is easy to
predict
so just running smgs on any browser
should give a speed up
but what's nice is that if you really
optimize for it specifically which
basically means optimizing typed arrays
very well
and a few other things you can get to
where firefox and chrome are which is
about the same speed as
java so that's pretty close to native
okay so a bit of background about sngs
it began as a research project
at mozilla basically the idea was
well every compiler generates some
pattern of javascript so there's many
many compilers to javascript
coffeescript google web toolkit they all
have a certain style that they generate
there were two compilers in the industry
m a script and the mandrill compiler
that compiled c plus plus to javascript
mandrel actually does a lot more but it
also compiles sql plus into javascript
and over time they experimented with
various subsets of javascript there's
various styles of output
but eventually they converged on what
turns out to be a very natural way to
implement
c plus in js it's basically what i
showed you earlier
typed arrays for data or xero et cetera
tricks to guarantee types
so this this pattern sort of emerged
naturally in the industry became useful
and basically we thought well why don't
we set out to formally define this
subset so we can optimize it even
further maybe find some bugs in it etc
and that's basically all smgs is a
formal
way to specify this pattern that grew
sort of
naturally okay so i've been talking
about mainly firefox and chrome and how
we can run
sort of at native speed on both of those
some of you may complain that i've not
been mentioning safari in ie and that's
very valid the whole point of the web is
that anybody with any web browser can
access content and it should look
reasonably similar if there are
huge differences in performance then the
web is losing
so let's talk a bit about those browsers
so about safari the first thing i want
to say is that
all browsers are working hard to
optimize javascript but they focus on
different aspects at different times so
here
are sun spider numbers where lower is
better and
safari is in blue you should be able to
see that it's beating all the other
browsers
so it's debatable if sunspider is the
best benchmark i
don't think it is but it measures a few
things of merit like startup speed
and this has been very important to
apple apparently and they've optimized
for it quite well beating out everyone
else
so how do they do on snjs code they're
great on that are they great on
everything else
they're close on some things farther on
others so safari is in light blue
and like before lower numbers are better
the numbers for firefox and chrome are
basically the same as before you can see
on primes for example and on copy and
corrections they're pretty close but on
several others they're a bit farther
and in fact it's possible to see what
the issue is so on memops
there's several times slower memphis
literally all it does is just hammer at
memory just reads reads reads writes
writes writes it doesn't do many
computations
on it doesn't do actual math it just
reads and writes basically
so they've just not optimized typed
arrays
to the extent that other browsers have
but it's not that hard to do so
hopefully that'll happen
and they're not standing still either
they're actually experimenting with
using
lvm as egypt which is pretty exciting
because no
other javascript engine has ever tried
this
and potentially it could give them very
large speedups
we'll just have to see how the project
goes
a few words about internet explorer
so ie6 was not a great browser
ie 7 and 8 got better 910
11 actually looks promising so it's in
pre-release i'm not going to show you
numbers because it's not the final
version i don't think it's fair to
measure but
it looks pretty good i've seen it beat
other browsers on a few things
it supports webgl which is huge first of
all for the standards process that they
finally
that they're finally playing ball with
with the webgl standard which there was
some
it was unclear whether they would so
that's great but it's also great
because webgl was the reason for the
invention of javascript typed arrays
they were basically a way to give binary
data to
uh to javascript for purposes of
graphics and textures turned out to be
useful for other things like
smgs so if they're optimizing webgl
they're optimizing typed arrays
we should expect smgs to be fast and
that's probably why as i mentioned i've
seen them do very well in a few
benchmarks
that's pretty promising overall the big
picture just to summarize
so far javascript can run at about half
the speed of native code
pretty much today on firefox and chrome
hopefully soon on other browsers
but of course half is just half we want
to get all the way down to native speed
so what i'd like to talk about now is
what are the remaining
issues so what's holding us back from
getting all the way to native so there
are three
that i'll talk about here first of which
are 32-bit floating point
numbers so javascript numbers are
doubles doubles are
64-bit doubles on many cpus take more
cycles to
compute they're larger they're more
precise not too surprising that
they take more effort although on modern
cpus often the difference is not big
but they also require more memory
bandwidth if you're constantly loading
and storing
64-bit values you're just pushing around
twice as much stuff and cache issues
can crop up and some simple tests on
firefox basically just replacing all the
double math with float math
show that shows that this could be about
a 10 to 20 percent
speed difference so on relevant code of
the code that uses floating point
heavily
we might be missing about 10 to 20
percent of the potential speed that we
could be getting
so can we actually get that speed in
some manner
the cool thing is that it's sometimes
possible to do 32-bit math as a pure
optimization
so without changing the language at all
just optimizing
existing codes sometimes we can achieve
this
this code is not the most clever thing
it just creates a flow 32 array
and then we assign to each element the
sum of the other two elements so zero is
the sum of what one and two etc
turns out that these additions right
here can be done as 32-bit
now the reason is pretty technical but
the overall idea is that we're reading
32-bit values because we're reading a
flow 32 array
we're adding them and then we're storing
them in a 32-bit array so we're sort of
rounding them to 32-bits so in broad
terms how floating point math works is
that when you add numbers you're adding
in
quote infinite precision as if you had
that
and then you round afterwards to the
right number so to 64-bit in javascript
so what happens here sort of logically
speaking is you round to 64-bit because
it's javascript and then you round to
32-bit
it turns out in many cases you can just
do the one rounding to 32-bit
assuming you're just adding two numbers
i'll talk more about that later so it's
not
always true but in this case it actually
is
and for that reason there's no there's
it's possible for js engines to optimize
this type of code
right now there's no reason this should
not run in floats and in fact there's
some code in firefox
to do it but as i sort of hinted this is
a fragile optimization just
changing that to add a plus one here
means it can't be optimized this really
depends on how
floats are defined so double numbers
have a certain number of bits in the
exponent and it turns out that by adding
three numbers you can generate a crazy
number
that if you round it to 64 bits and then
to 32
it's not the same as if you just rounded
it to 32.
so that's not great but es6 which is the
next
which is the proposal for the next
version of javascript has something
called math.f
round which basically as the name
implies rounds to
an f or a float and if we add a call to
math.f round here
basically we have we add two numbers we
do f round
then we add one and then we sort of
implicitly f round because we're saving
to a float332 array this becomes
optimizable
so using this approach we actually could
get a lot of the speed up of 32-bit
floats not all of it this might not work
for every type of code
but at least we should be able to get
some of that 10 to 20 percent
speed up that i mentioned okay the
second of three things that javascript
is missing right now for being fully
native
is simdi so simdia is single instruction
multiple data things like ssc and neon
probably most everyone here knows about
those
so basically instead of just adding four
numbers in parallel for example
you just create these chunks of four
values and then in a single operation
you just add the chunks sort of element
wise
so large parts of modern cpus are
dedicated to sim d
because it can be very efficient in some
cases you just add these things in
parallel when that's the type of math
that you're doing
which often you are in linear algebra
which is for rendering
and graphics and physics engines and
games in general
and it's also possible to use this from
c plus plus
mono dart a lot of languages and vms
give you the option to access
simdi because the benefits are nice so
can we do it in javascript
there's a proposal from john mccutchen
from google
basically wrote a spec for how we could
add this to the javascript language
here's a small sample from the spec so
basically we have a float32x4
type proposal for a new type in the
language you give it four floats
and it gives you this object which
represents sort of
four 32-bit values and then you have a
cmd object with things like cmd.add
and all the other natural operations
like multiply etc
these are immutable 128 bit values so
cmd.ad gives you a new one
back this is basically designed for what
cpus
provide in fact it's based on john's
work doing the same thing for the dart
vm
and it's pretty similar in other
languages and vms too because this is
really what cpus give you you can't
really
change these chunks of values you want
to just create them and then use them
which create
other ones so experience with doing this
in the past basically led to a
straightforward spec that
makes a lot of sense as i mentioned
there are potentially big speed ups from
this maybe even 300
percent if you're replacing four
sequential ads with a single
operation and collaboration is ongoing
with google mozilla intel and tc39 the
committee working on javascript
so it's been very fruitful and i think
this will really start to happen very
soon there's no reason not to the
benefits are clear there's a spec
so this looks pretty good
threads so this is the third of the
things that javascript
is kind of missing to be native so the
web has
web workers which let you use multiple
cpu cores it's actually had them for a
while
and you can even transfer typed arrays
so you can create data in one worker and
just
give it to the other worker which avoids
copying so you lose it but the other one
gets all the data
so this is pretty efficient but you
can't
read and write to the same data at the
same time
so this is good and bad it's good
because it prevents data races which is
a whole set of bugs that
javascript just doesn't even allow you
to have because all you can do is just
pass messages
and each thread itself can't race with
itself
but of course this is bad for cases
where you really do need multi-threaded
code like modern game engines
they really do need to be able to
potentially
cause data races although they're
careful to avoid them but they need the
ability to just read and write from the
same data
so what could be done here there are a
few proposals and experiments with code
but i would say it's pretty early in
this particular space
there's no clear direction for what the
right thing to do is
it would obviously require all vendors
all browser vendors to agree to
standardize something new
maybe complex depending on which
proposal sorry
makes sense and really the challenging
thing is not to implement it we could
tomorrow just let people access a typed
array from
web workers from multiple workers at the
same time that's easy we could just do
it
but there are questions about how that
fits in with the javascript language and
the rest of the web
because the web doesn't have data races
now as i mentioned so
this will require some careful thinking
and again this
this one is i'd say in pretty early
stages
the under the importance of it is
understood but there's still no clear
direction
for what to do so but with that said
there are those three things that are
missing
but even with all those things that are
not quite there yet many apps run at
native speed
so i showed you the epic citadel demo
before
i wanted to show you the javascript mess
demo but it requires a network
connection
so i will just tell you very briefly
about it
the mess project is something that
basically emulates old cpus old machines
like ataris and commodores
and it's a pretty large c plus plus code
base it's actually pretty complex
to simulate old machines the javascript
mess project basically just ported that
to javascript
and you can actually run all these
machines in in your browser which is
quite cool
so after the talk when i get to wi-fi
i'm going to tweet out tweet out a link
to these slides so you can just follow
the link and
actually play these things in your
browser but i think it's really a nice
case for something that's
very cool to do and you can't do it if
your browser isn't fast enough so fast
javascript makes
things like that possible something that
i do have a local demo for
is for example this bullet demo
which is simulating about not about
sorry
exactly 500 cubes
basically just dropping them on the
floor but you can see it's rendering at
somewhere between 50 and 60
physics frames per second
so again this is about half of native so
native could have done about twice as
many but even 500
is kind of nice i think
and for my last demo i'd like to show
you
something a little different
so this is a
this is sort of a demo about first
person shooter or fps
games
so this might look a little bit familiar
to you
this is the banana bread project which
pour sour bread and i'll tell you a bit
more about that in a second
what you might notice is that there's
aside from this sort of game that i'm
running in now and it's a first person
shooter i can fire
can change weapons etc i can even
add a bot which will
likely start to kill me but you can see
yeah i can just go into safe mode and
then i can create multiple dots that'll
just fight each other
so this is a full first person shooter
but there's also this thing over here
so you might think well that's a nice
movie playing over there
but actually it's not it's a fully
playable first-person shooter as well
so you can actually if you're tired from
playing one first-person shooter you can
play another first-person shooter in the
first person shooter
so this is basically doom although it's
using the doom code but not the doom
assets because they're not open source
but you can just by using different keys
start
playing if you've ever played doom then
this style of gameplay looks kind of
familiar
and there's switches and basically the
whole doom gameplay
is here and
basically and again if you're tired of
that you can just switch back to the
other game
and have fun etc
okay so what did i just show you
sorry so what did i just show you
eh the outer game
the first person shooter that i was in
is the banana red project which is a
port of sour breton and open source game
engine
basically from c plus plus the
javascript and webgl so much like epic
citadel but it's
it's open source and kind of smaller
inside it was another first person
shooter a boon
which is just the doom code specifically
the pr boom project which
has been working on the code since id
open sourced it
and the free doom content which is a set
of open source content for
doom style games and
i don't know why slides are skipping
but
how does this actually work so i was
running two games in
at once how did i do that so boone the
sort of
older style doom game runs in a web
worker
and all i do is i just proxy input
events to it so whenever i press keys
that i know are for the inner game
i just send it a message and it renders
its frames and it sends me a message
back
with those frames which are just typed
arrays with data
and then i just push those pixels to a
webgl texture
that's pretty much it so what was cool
about this
is that it took less than 100 lines of
code to integrate them so there's
actually a link to the code here
when you have the slides you can just
take take a look and this i think i mean
we're we're talking about native speed
here but aside from speed there are
other
nice things about the about the web so
it was really easy to do this once both
games were ported
just a hundred lines of code to
integrate them just basically the
natural proxying of events and getting
back frames
so it's a pretty nice fun project to do
and getting back to speed i think it's
cool that you can run both of these
games
at 60 frames per second on a pretty
average laptop so this is just a
thinkpad
with an intel gpu running linux not
the state-of-the-art in gaming speed but
it still runs those without a sweat and
even when i created multiple bots
shooting you could see
it was doing quite well and it's also
worth mentioning the
the doom game is so it's using a
software renderer
and of course the game is quite old at
this point
but the renderer was actually optimized
for x86
so i didn't spend any time to optimizing
it for javascript so it's actually
rendering in a much slower path than it
would be for native
but still it's more than fast enough to
run even though we're running both of
these games at the same time
and there's a lot of gpu traffic just
sending frames constantly
still it runs quite well
okay so that's basically what i have
just to summarize so javascript
is close right now and getting even
closer to native speed we can run
basically native apps
in many browsers hopefully soon all
browsers
and even on the missing pieces like cmd
and float32 etc there's a lot of
progress so we've seen big speed up so
far and we're going to continue to see
big speedups moving forward and
that is it for me thanks for listening